はい文章を間違った方法え読めるように
なった頭の中の嘘発見器の性能が抜群に
良くなよく発言の一番最後に言うように
なった
目的号馬では一番怖いのは銃撃と盗難では
なくムカデだどの国の政治家も嘘つきだと
学んだクリスマスイブに教会に行かなく
なったまあのビデオは教会みたいな形し
てるけどな他人にどう思われているか気に
するようになった
気が弱い奴だと思ってないよねアメリカの
照り焼きチキンお料理として見れなくなっ
たスペシャルアザーズをよく聞くように
なった柴犬が欲しくなくなった
可愛くないって言ってないから
入ってないからか編集毒から抜け出そうと
するのをやめたどう下なんか飲み物いる
そうだなぁ僕は水コーヒーと緑茶どっちが
良い引きこもりになっ
じゃなくて自営業を始めた毎年空想の怪物
にまねを投げつけるようになっこれって
吸血鬼をニンニクで防ぐのと同じ連はを
使うときになぜか一番最初にあっと言う
ようになった空気が読めるようになった
そしてマンガもたくさん読むようになった
漫画を読んでいる人の肩越しに頭を頻繁に
打つようになった今ではよく座禅している
と自分にも他人にも嘘をつくようになった
line スタンプのせいで表現力が劇的
に乏しくなった
今では人の親切心につけ込んでいるどう下
最後の一口いるオイルを空気はまだ読めて
ないは米顔が大きいか小さいか区別できる
ようになった
このスキル何の役に立つか誰か教えて一生
懸命勉強して覚えた園1の文法と漢字の
書き方を千部を忘れた
この悲劇に深い悲しみを
矜持と来ない
近々知恵なへぬ他人に自慢するためだけに
アニメを日本語で見るのやめたスーパーの
レジタウンととよくケンカするようになっ
たビニール袋は全然入りません
今の発言聞こえてなかったですか欲しい
ものをアマゾンで見てその後メルカリと楽
まで見て最終的にまたアマゾンに戻って
それを買うようになった念のためにいつも
原本を持ち歩くようになった
何の原本
今まで日本で作ってきたすべての資料の
原本付の中にウサギがいると信じるように
なったそして定期的に温泉に入れば超人に
なれると信じなくなったいわゆる上手冗談
をよく言うようになった